baye dame en laye prend le contraire
depuis plusieurs mois 300 collégiens
yvelinois travail en vue de la finale de
ce concours de robotique
ils ont dû apprendre et réaliser un
robot bateliers le thème retenu pour
cette quatrième édition
on a travaillé d'abord sur un plan mais
plan papier donc l'europe où ils
avancent à une certaine vitesse sur le
plateau qui est un peu plus granulés il
est il avance une autre vitesse faire
sera justement là avant d'avoir la
finalité le programme les élèves ont dû
créer un robot capable de récupérer des
conteneurs pour les emmener dans une
zone de déchargement porté par le
département des yvelines ce projet est
un fil rouge tout au long de l'année
scolaire et à plusieurs visée
pédagogique
l'objectif de ce concours est de ce
projet c'est travailler à une manière
différente des compétences du programme
scolaire
donc ils vont travailler l'expression
orale la programmation les mathématiques
les langues étrangères éventuellement
les arts plastiques tout ça de manière
transverse en travaillons pour certains
pour la plupart pour la première fois en
mode projet durant toute la journée le
jury composé de sept personnes à évaluer
les compétences et les réalisations des
dix collèges en lice on a une grille
danese qui nous permet d'analyser d'une
part la présentation qui est faite au
départ puis après de serpil que réalise
le robot il ya une note un peu général à
la fin et puis aussi le coup de coeur du
jury car il ya des fois il ya quelque
chose
personne ne pousse que l'heureuse cette
année c'est le collège montaigne de
conflans sainte honorine qui a remporté
le grand prix une cinquième édition est
d'ores et déjà programmée pour l'année
prochaine avec comme thème le robot
écolo